Speaker 1: Welcome back to the David Pakman show.
I am Ferron cousins from Ring of Fire, sitting in
for David today. And if you happen to like me,
you can go subscribe to my YouTube channels,
YouTube.com slash the Ring of fire and youtube.com
slash Ferran. Balanced. Now, let's move on here.
I got to talk about Jim Jordan, right? Chairman
of the House Judiciary Committee. Jim Jordan has
well, he's really stepped in it. I mean,
he's already in over his head. He's got
these weaponization hearings that even Fox
News has said have been a complete dud.
Jesse WATTERS asked a couple weeks ago, where are
the bombshells? You've been having these hearings,
not just Jim Jordan, but the other
Republicans. You've given us nothing.
But Jim Jordan is hell bent on making Manhattan
District Attorney Alvin Bragg pay for taking
on Donald Trump. So this week, Jim Jordan
announced that he and his Judiciary Committee,
they're going to take a little field trip up to
New York City on April 17th. And while they're on
their little field trip, they're going to hold
what they're calling a field hearing to talk
about the absolutely out of control crime rate
in Manhattan. And they're going to, of course,
try to tell us that Alvin Bragg, instead of taking
on the former president, needs to be taking on all
these all these darn shoplifters out here and
the muggers and the the spray painting vandals.
That's the real crime in New York City, not this
fraudulent business transaction for a multibillion
dollar corporation. No, no, no, no, no, no.
We don't worry about that. Alvin, you need to
go get the guy trying to steal Tylenol from Rite
Aid, as Eric Trump pointed out about a week ago.
So Jim Jordan heading to New York to tell us how
bad crime really is. But here's the thing. After
this was announced, Alvin Bragg's office issued
a statement that said, if Chairman Jordan truly
cared about public safety, he could take a short
drive to Columbus, Dayton, Cincinnati, Cleveland,
Akron or Toledo in his home state, instead of
using taxpayer dollars to travel hundreds of miles
this way. Now. The reason that this aide to Alvin
Bragg released this statement saying, hey, if you
want to look at crime, go look at your home state,
go look in your backyard, is because, as Business
Insider pointed out, Columbus, Ohio, which has a
population of approximately 970,000 people, closed
out 2022 with 15.4 murders per 100,000 citizens,
15.4 murders per 100,000 citizens. New York City,
on the other hand, closed out 2022 with a murder
rate of 5.2 murders per 100,000 citizens. Now,
correct me if I'm wrong, but wouldn't that
mean that right in Jim Jordan's backyard,
the murder rate is almost three times the
murder rate of New York City. Now. Yeah. I mean,
that that kind of seems like what that means. So
Jim Jordan, as Alvin Braggs office said, you want
to talk about the murder rate, You want to talk
about people getting killed out of control crime.
All you have to do is go home. Why don't you
worry about your own backyard and not about New
York City? Now, the crime rate. In New York and of
course, in California. We have heard Republicans
talk about that ad nauseum for very over a year.
Really, it was a big, big thing in the lead up to
the 2022 midterms. Then then they stopped talking
about it after the midterms because I guess crime
doesn't exist once elections are over. But now
that Alvin Bragg is prosecuting Donald Trump, we
have had Republicans across the board, not just in
Congress. I know my governor down here in Florida,
Ron DeSantis, while trashing Alvin Bragg, brought
up the crime rate there. So y'all want to talk
about crime rates. Let's talk about crime rates.
Let's talk about the fact that in New York City,
it is true that property crime has increased.
Property crime, of course, being vandalism,
theft, burglary, things like that. However,
the murder rate, the violent crime rate,
that includes non murders, but other violent
crime assaults of multiple kinds has decreased.
Now let's take a look at my state of Florida
down here. Now, in Florida, property crime has
gone down in the last few years. So we're not
seeing as many burglaries and muggings and,
you know, vandalism as they are in New York
City. But what has increased by double digits
down here in the state of Florida is the violent
crime rape rate. Excuse me. So here in Florida.
You're less likely to have somebody break into
your home and steal your stuff than New York City,
but you're more likely to be killed or
beaten to a pulp or maybe sexually assaulted.
But you don't ever hear the media
talking about that. Do you know?
What do they talk about? They talk about
the runaway crime rate in New York City,
in the blue states. Well, I got news for you,
media. The highest crime rates in the country.
Most of them out of the top 25 take
place all down here in the south.
What does the South have in common, folks? Yeah,
we're all red states down here. The highest crime
rates in the country are taking place in red
states. Run with an iron fist by Republicans.
But Republicans don't ever mention that in
the media does such a poor job of pushing
back on these narratives that blue states are
out of control with crime. That they miss the
fact that you're more likely to be the victim of a
crime in a red state than you are in a blue state.
And that's why I love that Bragg's office
has pushed back on Jim Jordan. They've pushed
back on him repeatedly. But this is a big one.
The murder rate in Jim Jordan's own district.
Is far higher than it is in New York City. But
Jim Jordan is going to waste our tax dollars.
He's going to waste everybody's time. Go into
New York. What? Trying to find victims of violent
crime. Are you hoping to roam the streets like a
vigilante? You know, maybe you're going to pull
a Batman and beat up somebody trying to take a
woman's purse from the street? I don't know what
Jim Jordan's going to do, but I do know that based
on everything we've seen Jim Jordan do this year,
it's probably going to backfire and
make him look like a total idiot.